pecsi voiture en spécialiste en cyber
sécurité bonjour steve howey faut dire
tout d'abord c'est genre de canular
c'est pas nouveau c'est pas la première
fois qu'on voit ça au canada exactement
puis le dernier au canada qui était
quand même très vite médiatisé et en
2014 à ottawa alors que un jeune de la
région de paris viii n'ont été accusés
de 60 chefs d'accusation pour avoir
proliféré justement des appels de soi
thing un peu partout en amérique sedan
et même un appel à la bombe et l'école
georges vanier de laval ouais donc soit
thing si ça veut dire qu'on en place des
appels anonymes ont fait on parle d'une
possible menace pour voir déployer le
groupe d'intervention tactique comme on
l'a vu à montréal est fière
oui et ses parents que s'étaient vus
encore l'eau dans le bio que quand même
cinq six sept ans dans la communauté des
jeux du jeu en ligne que les jeunes
justement pour se venger soit de
mauvaises pratiques dans un jeu oublier
parce que c'est du mauvais perdant s'en
prennent de justement avec les
perfections technologique de placer des
appels au service 9 heures et accolades
en simulant qu'il ya violence ou tout
simplement en disant que y'a vraiment
quelqu'un d'armé qui veulent faire du
mal à des gens pour comme on a vu hier
prise d'otages et à ce moment là les
forces de l'ordre n'ont pas le choix de
prendre tous les moyens nécessaires pour
encore là encore que ça soit vrai qu'il
ne fasse pas d'erreurs et donc ici ça
s'est très bien déroulé on a vu que une
bonne fin mais il ya d'autres lieux aux
états unis en 2010 est d'ailleurs et en
2015 qu'il ya des gens qui en ont été un
canot décédé d'opérations policières
généré exactement parce que les
policiers sont sur le qui vive
c'est normal l'intervention va de
l'avant selon l'information qu'ils ont
donc la première étape c'est qu'ils
doivent valider ces serrures un canular
ou une situation réelle et après ça sent
suis justement déroulement des
opérations
bon dans le cas qui nous préoccupe ce
matin c'est ce qui s'est passé donc chez
ubisoft
on parle de deux appels anonymes 1 entre
autres au 9-1-1 et ayant un appel qui
affichait le numéro d'ubisoft tandis que
l'autre semblait provenir des états unis
est ce que ça peut être possible de
retracer qui a fait ses appels il l'est
pas est possible de retracer mais ça va
être très du ccar
parce que la technologie comme on la
connait on peut masquer sa trace
électronique par le simple d'utilisation
exemple de la technologie du vpn
c'est-à-dire de connecter à vers un
autre réseau et ça donne l'impression
que ça vient d'un autre source donc
l'appel par loin très bien déplacés de
la région de montréal et ça donne
l'impression que ça vient des états unis
tout comme ça peut venir justement des
états unis et les forces de l'ordre nous
devrons à ce moment le faire le travail
d enquête électronique mais c'est quand
même très difficile de procéder dans ce
hit dans cette avenue avec la
technologie comme on la connaît
et pour vous avec les éléments dont on
dispose présentement ça vous semble
réellement être un événement de sweeting
si on rassemble les éléments pour qu'on
a actuellement caroline une compagnie
kenyane un jeu en ligne récemment comme
assassin's creed on dit dans le
reportage ou bien si tu sais ce que ça
rapport justement avec les multiples
corps des dénonciations de mal de
l'environnement de travail malsain que
c'est qu'on a appris dans les dernières
semaines
donc il ya toutes ces éléments là qui
devront être analysés même chose
certaine cette pratique l'heure je dis
ça peut persister il ya d'autres gens
qui peuvent en devenir victime parce que
la technologie c'est l'époque bien
entretenues programmé ça va laisser la
porte ouverte qui est qu'on peut
s'introduire vers une compagnie est
placé l'appel de l'emploi en pensant que
c'est de l'intérêt mais nécessairement
ça veut dire aussi que des gens avec peu
avec une intention malicieuse va avec
peu de moyens peuvent triple à ma place
et l'appel à une fin et à ce moment-là
ça crie tout ce branle bas de combat là
est ce qui peut dissuader bien sûr ce
sont les les peines de prison qui
peuvent survenir si on arrive à arrêter
quelqu'un dans ce genre de méfaits à six
voies terrasse merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin le plaisir
aujourd'hui